[Music]
all right let's go to matt and baton
rouge what's up dude
hey how's it going dr john it's uh great
to actually talk to you it's great to
talk to you you've never heard the uh do
you all just walk around in baton rouge
singing the baton rouge song all the
time
i have no idea i am a med i am a metal
guy straight up i'm not a country guy
whatsoever listen i wasn't either
i i'm with you
but then someone showed me garth brooks
and he was my gateway drug
and uh so hey go get a garth brooks
record
or maybe because you were born in the
21st century just pull up spotify and
check it out all right hey so what's up
man i have i have quite a bit of vinyl
collection myself anyways
so
i need some advice on how to navigate
what i kind of feel is
a
sort of
conflict or misalignment in personal
values between
myself and my girlfriend
it's causing quite a bit of tension in
our relationship and i would like for it
to not be
the end of our relationship but i'm
having trouble seeing any kind of
solution that doesn't result in
either
us breaking up or resentment for one
toward the other either way somewhere
further down the road uh
so so it's either about sex or money
which one is it
uh it's
not
i guess it's almost tangentially about
sex but not quite okay um
so basically she took a she's taken i'm
just gonna say she's taking a job that's
causing her to have to do some things
that i am uncomfortable with personally
dude you got to be more specific man
what are you talking about
all right so uh it's going to sound kind
of trivial but i'll just get into it
she's she does a lot of community
theater acting and local productions and
whatnot and she's taking a role that's
basically required her to
basically become a stripper um
you know i understand that it's just
kind of
playing pretend and playing dress up and
telling the story and all that but
i'm still uncomfortable with the
physical reality of my girlfriend doing
some
you know
getting
almost naked and doing
erotic things on stage in public for a
bunch of people i'm just i'm
uncomfortable with that okay um
and
uh the bigger issue is that when i try
to bring it up
um try to tell her about it look i'm
just you know this is making me
uncomfortable
um
it doesn't go that well it results in a
pretty big argument and
the end result is you know
hey i understand you feel this way but
this is my dream and so i'm gonna do
what i want to achieve it
okay so that's why that's why i'm kinda
so that's what kind of leads me to the
values conclusion yeah i guess yeah yeah
but you got a very clear answer
i'm choosing this over you and it sounds
like
you don't like that answer i don't want
to hear that answer and what i will tell
you is a you're allowed to have any
value you want
okay right nobody gets a say in that and
there will be a bajillion people who
comment on youtube or whatever with this
clip comes out and they'll be like
throwing their nobody gets a vote on
your values because they're yours right
okay
and when you get married with somebody
you you decide to share them okay
right but you've stated your values out
loud
i don't want um
to be connected to somebody who's going
to show her body off in this in a public
forum right right right wrong or
indifferent that's you're one of your
values
and she has said
i
one of my values is i want to be in
theater and this is a part of being an
actress and so this is what i want
which is a roundabout way of saying this
my values are more important than yours
yeah yeah i've kind of had this
conversation over and over again in my
head and i've kind of come to that
conclusion i'm just
it's not it's not really a math problem
it's just it's just pretty direct
yeah yeah
and so what i would tell you is never
never compromise your values for a job
for a girlfriend for a boyfriend like
when you go down that road it gets hard
so you may have heard me say on the show
all the time there's a big difference
between beliefs and values and i think
belief should be pushed and pulled
that's why i'm always i don't post
people ask me the most common question i
get is what books are you reading and i
rarely post them
because i'm always reading things that
are diametrically opposed to what i
already believe because i want to
pressure test my beliefs right or i want
to learn new things when it comes to my
values man um over time i've i've gotten
fewer of them
and they've expanded and they've become
more concrete does that make sense
right so how old are you now
uh 28 she's 27. okay so you got you got
a set of values right now you're going
to look back when you're 40 and be like
oh gosh those are some of my values but
the answer is yes they are
and they just are right so the question
is are you going to compromise your
values
um
or are you going to say hey this is this
is a deal breaker for me
oh
yeah yeah that's that's
i think i listened enough to the show
that i kind of that that was pretty much
the the thing i was expecting i'm just
having i guess i'm just having trouble
coming to uh
it's a hard conclusion to come to i
guess yeah
well here's why it's not a hard
conclusion
um
tell me if this math works out i'm doing
this in real time okay so i'm just i'm
thinking this as i go
you have a core value that's about you
and about um intimacy in your
relationship right
correct
and
she has a core value about
acting
is that right yes right
so does it work tell me if i'm wrong
does it work that you are choosing
a core value
that sits within you and she is choosing
a thing over you does that work
because that's what it feels like
yeah that's you know that's and that's
what it feels like to to me too and and
i i've listened enough to the show to
i've heard you say several times you
know behavior is a language and
to me
what what this is saying to me is hey my
dream is more important than you and how
you feel about it uh
and that you know that's what i'm that's
that's how i'm feeling about the
situation that's that's what i feel that
she's saying to me
have you said that to her have you have
you said that
not that specifically but i've i've said
that
um and i think
i don't
i definitely don't think that she's
specifically trying to do something that
hurts me
um i just don't think she thinks about
it in the same way that i do to me it is
an intimacy thing and
you know to me
doing that on stage that kind of thing
is a level of intimacy that i feel
should be reserved something that we
should just share between the two of us
and not something that should be shared
in public yeah and that that's what that
that's why it kind of bothers me but to
her she doesn't think of it that way to
her it's just a performance it's uh
telling a story playing a character that
kind of thing the intimacy thing and it
you know it could be that she just
doesn't you know she has a whole
different bunch of intimacy issues that
we could spend the whole show talking
about um you know i don't know well i i
don't know that i'd characterize them as
issues they're just different than yours
yeah right yeah yeah and
here's a common misconception
you can love somebody
and you can be sexually attracted to
somebody
yet have very different values meaning
that you can love somebody i've got
friends and family that i love
but good god almighty we vote
differently and we think differently
about issues and we've got very
different ways of communicating with
people and we have very different values
there's been people that i'm sexually
attracted to but we had different values
and so we didn't i didn't pursue a
long-term relation you see what i'm
saying like
yeah yeah it didn't play out in the long
term my wife and i shared the same
values when she was my girlfriend and
that's ultimately what brought us
together see what i'm saying so
those two things often like well we i
love her and i'm attracted to her and
vice versa then why can't this thing
work those two things aren't always the
bellwether here right yeah you want to
be aligned in the values um
how long have you all been dating
oh it's been it's been a couple years
now this is the first time anything like
this has has come up
my guess is
um so you've heard me talk about
pictures and words you ever talked to me
about heard me say that
yeah yeah yeah okay
it wouldn't surprise me like her wanting
to be an actress
can't be a surprise right she's no no
absolutely absolutely i you know i love
that about her and i love that she's
doing that just that this this one
aspect of it is is causing me some
discomfort so have you
ever been watching a movie and there's
nudity in the movie and you all talk
about it on the way home like
man would you ever do that or i would
never do it has that ever come up when
the two years all been been dating
it it came it came up
over this conversation um that you know
she wants to and
and it was basically kind of the same
thing like look i you know i really
wouldn't be comfortable if you if you
would do some stuff like that and the
response was basically the same like
look i'm gonna do whatever i have to do
to achieve this dream uh you know
so
when it comes back to the pictures and
words
i can imagine
you've known you're dating an actress
right
and the actress you're dating has told
you
for two years this is a dream of mine
yeah y'all have used the same word but
you had very different pictures of what
actress meant
see what i'm saying and both of you
right now are feeling like the other
person has pulled a bait and switch
yeah you're gonna feel like i want her
to be an actress yeah i support you
fully whoa put your clothes back on and
she's looking at you like i told you
she's gonna be an actress and y'all just
had different pictures of what actress
meant
and for her it means whatever it takes
i'll do whatever the director says so i
can get into this role
and
um for you it's
i want to reserve something that's just
ours
yeah that's that's that's fair
you hit it right on the head so i think
it's fair for you to sit down and say
start there
i get that you feel like i'm pulling a
bait and switch on you i've heard
actress for all these for for a couple
of years
and
it never even occurred to me that this
was a part of
your picture of what actress meant
and so i want you to know i'm not trying
to deceive you i'm not i i'm not trying
to as you're walking out on the stage be
like whoa don't do that don't do that
um
and ultimately tell her i love you
and
i am or am not going to be a part of
this moving forward
and what you're doing there is you're
taking full 100 ownership of your values
and make no mistake
our values will always cost us something
always
and i know this is a steep price to pay
because you love this person right you
had plans with her right you all had
y'all talked about the future you're
y'all are you're 20 years old you're two
years into this thing right
yeah yeah absolutely
here's the here's the part i'm concerned
about
one of the two of you she drops out of
the play
or
you say cool but i'm not gonna go
or you go and you squirm and it's
uncomfortable the whole time
that is man that is a
race track to resentment
and that's that's exactly what what i'm
struggling with that's the the only two
compromises i see is either you know she
stopped you know she
forever now sees me as the one that
wrote either that ruined her dream
because she
you know had to
um
skip skip out on doing certain
opportunities because of me
or
you know i just go along and and you
know continue to just kind of sit by
while she does stuff that that i'm
uncomfortable with and so either way
would lead to one of us resenting one
another down the road and that's what
i'm worried about yeah i think it's a
very it's a very legitimate true worry
the path forward here though is this
please keep this in your heart and mind
these are your values
and so if it ultimately ends your
relationship if you all end up saying
this is this is as far as we go it's
been a great run i love you and i wish
you nothing but the best
here's a dif i have a different picture
of the way my life's gonna go then what
you're the way your life is gonna go
um
then so then so be it but
don't leave angry with her
because what she's doing is the same
thing you're doing just on the other
side of the coin she's holding to her
set of values whether you agree with
them or not and we can debate that all
day long whether what she's doing is
wise or smart or good or right all those
things
the reality is though you you'll have
you have a line and she's got a line and
now you all have got a gap between the
two of you and you're both standing
behind each other's line going are you
coming over here are you coming over
here
yeah and so the honest way the way it
usually happens is you get mad because
you have to garner the energy to do what
you got to do
[Music]
the more integrous way forward is a
humble quiet vulnerable this is as far
as i can go
and i'm gonna own this
see what i'm saying
yeah i'll also say this
um
this is gonna help this this is one of
those things when you ask a billionaire
like what should i do and like follow
your passion you're like shut up like
there's one billionaire for every
you know
10 000 unemployed right so
take this for what for what what what
what it's worth
there came a moment when my wife and i
we dated for i think we were dating for
three or four years of the time she was
weird still boyfriend girlfriend
and i sat down with her and said look
if all of my dreams come true
and all of your dreams come true we end
up on separate planets
and you are pursuing your dreams as hard
as you can
and i'm pursuing mine as hard as i can
and we've been trying to do this
together it's not going to work
so let's save each other the misery and
the heartache when we get there and call
it now and we broke up and it was hard
and it was one of those things that like
i thought it was right at the time i
think it was right at the time
and within the next year
what my dream for my life was shifted
radically
and hers changed to so see what i'm
saying so yeah yeah hear me say that
just because you say hey this is this is
as far as i can go that doesn't mean
it's the death and the end forever
but be prepared for it to be right
right
um or
man have a hard conversation with
yourself and say no i'm okay with this
yeah but whatever it is take ownership
of it okay
for sure i wish i had some some like i
wish i had some like oh no just say this
these are hard and for everybody
watching to listen please don't just
bomb the comment section here for matt
right
i want as a culture us to get to a place
where we honor a each other's values
b we have hard discussions about why is
this your value and why is this mine and
let's engage in this conversation
and let's be integrous about shaking
hands and saying hey i'm going to go my
go my way here
i realize that my boss has different
values than me and he or she is asking
for different values of their employees
and these aren't my values and so i'm
gonna i know i just moved across the
country here i know this pays great i'm
not gonna throw grenades and try to
shift and it i i'm going to step off and
i'm going to go
there's a few core values that all of us
in a society have to have right we can
debate those all day long but there's
there's some core ones on treating
people with dignity and respect and
loving everybody all those things
but there's just going to be moments in
our lives when we have to be okay with
walking up and saying hey this is a
value i love you i'ma shake hands
um but it's time for me to head off in
this other direction
and i'm taking ownership of it
so it's hard matt i'm sorry man and i
know it's hard for your girlfriend too
um the whole thing's hard and um
i wish you the best let me know how that
hard conversation goes and uh i'll walk
with you every step of the way my
brother